the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
alright so finally it's our last
recitation and I know it's my favorite
topic cryptography because I work in
this area probably a little bit more
than what's required to tell you so my
stations is access more primitives so
we'll introduce several more primitives
that may be useful to your future work
or study and so the first one is digital
signature
so we have briefly mentioned digital
signatures in the lecture but mainly as
an application of hash right so now I'm
going to introduce it as a standalone
primitive so as you may have already
known digital signature is used for
verifying message authenticity and it's
a pair of function sigh and verify so
sign takes a secret key and a message it
outputs a signature which we refer to as
Sigma and verify takes a public key a
message and a signature and outputs
either true or false it accepts the
signature or reject so we use secret key
to cyan public key to verify that means
so if I want to send a message I should
be the only one who is able to sign it
and everyone can verify that this
message indeed comes from me so what
properties do we want from digital
signatures
yeah any any thoughts all that okay
that's definitely one yeah I'll put a
general more general description of what
you just said any other answers
okay what was her name Hillgrove says
one message a message should only have
one signature okay let's think about
whether that's necessary so if if my
algorithm is a randomized one that for
for the same message output many
possible signatures so yeah why is that
bad for any of them they will verify if
that's how my algorithm works I think
that's that's fine it's okay it's not a
bad thing actually randomized signature
is considered more secure there are less
efficient
any other thoughts
that's definitely one but I will happen
have we haven't got any scheme yet so we
care about functionality first there are
faster signatures and slower ones okay
so the first one is actually very
trivial we first want correctness what
does that mean that means if this Sigma
is indeed generated by the sine function
that verified by the output one
otherwise it should power output zero
that's actually the first and the most
basic property we want okay I don't want
to write it because it's okay so the
other one so your answer is very close
that you don't want to extract the
secret key but to make it more general
what we really want is unforgeable tea
that means if I have the secret key and
someone else in the adversary who does
not have the secret key should not be
able to sign the message to pretend to
be me so they should not produce be able
to do this
I'm star Sigma star such that such that
he's verifies make sense so what you
said is a special case of this so if
they can extract somehow extract the
secret key then of course they can
Forge my signature on any other messages
right but we do want to also prevent the
attack where they do not they cannot
extract the secret key but they somehow
can forge another signature but usually
we want to make the adversary adversary
more powerful because well then we have
higher confidence that we won't be
attacked so an adversary it's totally
reasonable for it to see a bunch of
messages from me because I am signing
messages and output it to the world so
an adversary may have seen some of the
message signature pairs I generated
right but still we do not want it to
create a forgery and how is that defined
because he can definitely send one of
these back that's a valid message
signature pair
so our unforgeable 'ti requirement is
defined to be he should not be able to
send such a pair where MSTAR is
different from any message he has
already seen
there is no way to prevent the adversary
from sending one of the message
signature pairs he had seen before
okay so far pretty straightforward now
how can we get digital signatures so in
the early days researchers and it's
actually great computer scientists they
proposed a digital signature can be
implemented as the inverse of public key
encryption
well that's not me so I'll use RSA as an
example so RSA encryption is m to the e
mod n all right the question is C to the
D mod n
so the first attempt is we will just use
this as our sine function and use this
that's our verify function okay so now
this symbol is a little bit confusing so
now I'm signing a message I call C okay
good I mean let me actually change it
this is RSA encryption I'm going to
transform it into signature scheme where
sign science a message and verify raise
the signature Sigma to the power of E
and checks whether or not I get back my
message
so this actually makes a lot of sense
why because mm-hmm think of it think of
the M as a ciphertext then if I decrypt
it and then we encrypt it I should get
back my ciphertext right so correctness
we have correctness and why is it done
fortune
because an attacker does not have the
secret key so he should should not be
able to decrypt this this M here cannot
one this algorithm right that's the
reason he behind it so far so good
but unfortunately it is broken and so
I'll give you say several minutes to
think about it can you come up with an
attack a forgery you can see a bunch of
messages and then output a forgery for a
message you have you haven't seen before
so it's the algorithm clear
okay we speak love it exactly okay so if
anniversary had seen a bunch of messages
because RSA it has this sometimes good
sometimes nice sometimes bad property
that it's multiplicative homomorphic or
well you see a less fancy award
malleable so if an adversary sees this
messages it can set m star to be m1
times m2 and Sigma star to Sigma 1 times
Sigma 2 all right you can check this is
a valid signature message a signature
pair you take this entire teint raise to
D and that's the race to be individually
and then multiplied together and that's
exactly this message here attack 1 okay
there's actually another attack
that's even simpler and tells you the
scheme is even more broken
so all I want to do is that come up with
a Sigma when it raised to me that's
equal to M right okay so I'm going to
select our Sigma compute and Sigma raise
to e because E is my public key Mar then
I can do that right and then of course
Sigma M I'm sorry I'm Sigma okay I
select a signature first and I raise it
to the power of E I get a very strange
message but doesn't matter
that's my forgery
okay so now you can see this scheme is
well basically totally broken but they
actually come from our several renowned
scientist why is that a case because
actually that definition didn't exist
when they were trying to when when they
were working on this problem so that
definition looks obvious today but it's
actually not obvious at all and I think
it's this this algorithms come in this
70s 78 and 82 called Watson and McCauley
two professors from MIT proposed the
definition for signature encryption and
basically everything in cryptography and
they want another touring word for that
okay so let's try to fix it
any any ideas
we do not want to change the framework
let's still use RSA and combine it with
some other primitive you have seen to
try to fix it
what we want to do we want to break this
multiplicative property
I am we want to break this all this step
whatever is called go ahead
change this end yeah okay right now just
to remind you is a product of two primes
okay PQ mm-hmm it's a product of two
primes and that's how RSA works what do
I do
oh go ahead exactly let's just make a
small change so sign will be hash of M
raised to D and verify will be yeah I
just burped okay just check what the
hash of M equals signature is to eat
this indeed fixes the these attacks why
because now you need well if you do this
hash of M + 1 times hash of M 2 is not
going to be hash of M stop right hash is
supposed to be pseudo-random that's not
going to work and here what your attack
I need to do is to find hash of M such
that this Ray's Sigma raise to e it can
still do this but it does not know what
this message is because of the
one-wayness of hash function if we use a
good hash function there and it indeed
fixes both the attacks but we have seen
in the lecture that this hash function
also needs to be collision resistant
with that question yeah the message oh
okay mmm good point
oh no but okay you are talking about
this attack right so the attacker needs
to find a public message but all he can
do is select the Sigma and raise it to E
that's going to be its hasha BAM right
and then he cannot figure out what this
M is
okay so he then he gets hash of M one
you got hash of M two but you need to
find an M star such that it's hash it's
the multiplication of these two and yeah
it does not know how to find that
message
okay so if the hash is not
multiplicative one-way and collision
resistant then it seems that we have
fixed all the attacks we know however
how do we know there are no other
attacks so actually indeed this is a
good idea
we have several national standards that
just use this but slightly differently I
can just for your information and so
there's a standard code and see I got
whatever X through nine point five point
one it uses RSA on this weird padding so
it takes the hash of the message and pad
with this hack stream and pretend it and
append another hack string okay why why
do they do that they don't know either
but they just think it's probably more
secure than only using a hash there is
another standard that pads a different
string and the different string here and
it doesn't matter so that's indeed a
weakness of these types of approaches so
their security is what we call ad hoc
they do we do not know how to break them
but we do not know how to prove they are
secure either yet that's what people do
in practice
so unfortunately that's all I can tell
you today so how not to construct a
digital signature I cannot tell you how
to construct a secure digital signature
because that's the that's out of the
scope of this class and its major topic
in cryptography
any questions so far
yes it's one way collision-resistant
okay good question so okay I mean let's
be clear what you say okay can you
answer your own question
yeah how how does it create a boundary I
just answered your own question let
everyone else know maybe they have the
same question
answer your own question
yeah what's the problem problem is that
a hash function is a public function
that everybody can compute right so the
attacker just choose a message compute
its hash and so using a hash it's not a
signature but good point I'm actually
coming to that so so far we have seen
three major primitives private key
encryption public key encryption and
digital signature so if we categorize
them a little bit so these two are
asymmetric key right they are public key
and secret key
this one is symmetric key and these two
are for secrecy they are trying to hide
the message and this one is for
integrity meaning the message is what
the sender sends okay so you can see we
are missing one primitive here what if
the two parties they do share a secret
key and one party wants to verify the
other party the message indeed comes
from the other party so indeed we do
have a primitive for that it's called
message authentication code so it's
definition is basically exactly the same
as digital signature okay I'm just going
to change it here except that it has
only one key
so the sine function is replaced by a
Mac and there's no notion of secret key
and public key we have only one key and
how do we verify
okay so verify function basically just
becomes the other guy also recompute the
Mac of the message and check whether
that's the signature so verifier just to
recompute and compare
okay correctness we also want
correctness we also want our forge
ability and is defined exactly in the
same way now actually I would have asked
this question here is hash valid knack
yes I still know because Mac is a public
function everyone can compute and it's
trivial to come up with a forgery okay
so thank you for asking that question
but the hash is actually very close
how can we get a message authentication
code so several ideas
can we just hash the key concatenated
with the message then some mother random
attacker who doesn't have the key does
not know how to compute this thing right
that's a reasonable idea but well if we
can do it this way how about we do the
message concatenated with the key or if
you want you can do key concatenate with
message and then concatenate with the
key so it turns out this doesn't work
for some very advanced the reasons and
this one may or may not for sha-1 it
doesn't work unfortunately and for sharp
three that's the replacement for shower
and Shasha - it actually works so the
simply simple as the Mac we can imagine
is just to choose shatori as the hash
function and input is the key and then
the message okay but not the other way
that's also just FYI purpose oh by the
way there's another reasonable thought
that is how about we encrypt the hash
right everyone can compute the hash but
they don't have to know how to encrypt
if I use a secret key encryption
oh this turns out to be wrong as well
okay that's teaching those digital
signature and Mac a one caveat here our
unforgeable ax T is defined this way a
little bit strange but makes sense but
it indeed has some weakness in some
applications so imagine say I sent you a
message today its recitation is canceled
and it has my signature on it right so
you can verify it indeed comes from me
but once I sent that message everywhere
view has that message right so next week
one of you can send that message again
saying today's presentation is cancelled
then you have no idea whether it's
indeed me sending a message again or
someone doing a April Fool's Day joke so
how do we do how do we prevent that well
of course one thing I can do is if I'm
smart I'll say today like parenthesis
May 8th recitation is canceled right
then you cannot repeat that message but
we want to protect humans stability
right that's the whole point of
cryptography so one thing we could do
let's see
very simple modification when I sign a
message
I'll sign one concatenated with my
message right next time I sign to
concatenate with my message and then
three four and just have this counter
that keeps incrementing ten that really
fixes so you can verify if you receive
the same message with the same counter
then you know it's someone else who is
presenting it okay so that's one thing
we need to do for signature impact
practical use now I consider another
totally different application so say I
think everyone uses Google Drive Dropbox
something like that right you store a
bunch of files this cloud server
uou you are here about say cellphone and
you can access your files but how do you
know when you read a file it is indeed
your file are modified how do you know
maybe Google messes with you oh there's
someone in the middle who changes your
file so ok usually most people do not
care about that but well in cryptography
we do care about them so in that case
Mac and signatures do not help us why
because if you just store in a Mac
alongside each file what went wrong
okay but if they modify the file they do
not know how to generate a map for their
version of the file but what they can do
is you have this file and then you come
and write it now you generate a new Mac
when you read it they give you the old
version that has the valid signature or
Mac on it because you generated that for
it see you'll see the problem you
haven't seen the problem okay
okay so you have this file alright you
generate a Mac but you somehow us at
some point you want to update the file
okay you want to you update this file to
this file Prime and generate a new Mac
maybe then file double prime Mac double
Prime in this application we want
freshness when you read this file you
want the latest version of the file so
it should be the it should be what you
wrote there last time but when you're
trying to read a file an attacker can
give you this pair right if you check
the Mac it's going to match this is also
a valid message Mac there okay now
everyone sees the problem okay so what
can we do well one thing we could do is
store all these Mac's
here on your phone right Mac one Mac to
a Mac for every single file but if you
do that in fact we do not need Mac
anymore or we can just use hash
okay so I'll say Sigma are you Sigma's
they mean hashes well this is probably
good enough in practice so I'll say
these files are X 1 X 2 X 3 X 4 now you
just create a hash for each of them and
store them locally and the model here is
studing and an attacker cannot modify
files on your own computer or on your
own phone and then you can download the
file match compares it with the latest
version of the hash and then you are
convinced that it's the latest version
this is probably a good enough solution
the only downside is that we do have to
store a lot of hashes if you need a if
you have a lot of files or in our
algorithmic terminology we say your
space complexity is all then right here
I mean your local space
so can we somehow reduce the space
complete lack of space complexity well
one thing we could do is to concatenate
all the parts together generate a single
hash and store that one hash
- everything in one try then we do have
of one space but there's a bigger
problem anyone tell me
okay I think I think you are thinking in
a right thing so how do I verify if I
wanna I cannot verify a single file I
have to download all the files and we
compute a hash to verify so the time
complexity is o event and also if I want
to update this file I have to recompute
the hash right that involves again
downloading all the files and feed them
into that hash
and we do have a better solution than
both of them which is called a hash tree
or Marco tree it's invented by Merkel
what we will do is so first for every
file we're going to create a hash okay
okay let me again use Sigma because H is
unclear but it's a hash value or a hash
function so I said a hash tree and guess
what then what's the next step to do
yeah exactly
we're going to create our okay Sigma 5
which is the hash of Sigma 1
concatenated with Sigma 2 okay so we do
the same thing here
so you all know what it is right I don't
need to write it and keep going until we
get a root hash and then we're going to
store this thing locally on this side
so what's the local storage complexity
of one we're only storing one hash
locally what's the time complexity okay
so how do I verify mm-hmm yeah
login yeah how do I verify I need to so
first verify if this cache mattress and
then breathe this hash and verify
whether this link matches and verify
whether this one matches and then I'm
done right if I want to update I also
need to update this hash then it causes
this hash to change and then that has to
change but it's always some path in that
tree
it doesn't affect anything globally
question I am NOT yeah I have to go
ahead and read it from Google Drive or
Dropbox
okay yeah so that's that's the next
thing we're going to do is this secure
or in other words canned and adversary
changes one of the files and somehow
maintain the same routes hash right
that's your question
of course we assume the hashes
collision-resistant or I should say if
the hash is collision resistant
then this hash tree is collision
resistant any intuition
well anyone wants to approve it
yep
yeah correct so okay so I'll just repeat
what you said but I'll start with the
leaf because that's easier for me to
think about so say I changed this one
this block now I claim this hash here
will change if it doesn't then I have
found the collision right because this
x4 prime has the same hash as the
original x4 okay so if this Sigma 4
changes then Sigma 6 will change
otherwise I have found the collision
it's the Sigma 3 concatenated with the
new Sigma 4 it's my creation so same
argument either this one changes or I
have found a collision I repeat the
argument or all the way to the
okay
any question about that
yeah okay so then we have found the
collision that is Sigma Sigma 1
concatenated with Sigma 2
that's a collision with the music more
and concatenated with the Nu Sigma 2
make sense
oh so if the concatenation stay the same
that means both of them are the same
right because so I'm not sure if I
understand your question so if
concatenation is basically just a bunch
of bits then followed by another bunch
of bits right if this entire thing is
the same that means this part is the
same and this part is the same right and
if you're Sigma 1 Nu Sigma 1 is the same
as your old Sigma 1 that means I have
found a collision here because you
changed it but your Sigma doesn't change
all right
so lastly I'm going to I'm going to do a
quick review of the knapsack problem
because I think in the lecture
Sweeney ran out of time and didn't
measure everything thank so if you
recall the knapsack cryptosystem it says
we have a knapsack problem
okay you want to un and then we're going
to transform it okay this is a super
increasing sequence I'm going to
transform into a general one by
multiplying an N and then mod M right so
this is an easy problem and that is a
hard problem so how do I encrypt I'm
going to take a subset sum which is M I
WI where am i is the i-th in a message
so how do I decrypt I'll take this
transform this s back to the to the
super increasing domain by multiplier
inverse of n so that's going to be
inverse of n multiplied by this mi WI
that's how I encrypt it and then each WI
is n times u I so possible right so that
gives me mi times UI Sigma of course
every step is modulo M so the first
thing I'm going to claim is that M has
to be larger than Sigma UI if that's the
case then the T my T is just this subset
son so if I solve this knapsack problem
I got the same answer as solving the
original the general knapsack problem
right if my M is not that large
the ban is too small then I have a
problem because then my T will be the
subset sum minus some multiple of M
right then it's a different problem I do
not get the same message back
okay then we have a problem
so because we define density to be n
over the log of max UI does everyone
remember this part so each UI is in the
range of 1 to M or maybe 0 to M if I
have a bunch of them then okay it's not
super rigorous if I have a bunch of them
chances are that some of them are very
close to M because it's unlikely that
all of them are small so this thing is
roughly n over log of
so then we have a dilemma if we set em
to be a small number then my density is
fine but that means all of my UIs needs
to be small because M needs to be
greater than the sum of them oh if all
the UI's are small then I have a very
limited choices of them then actually an
attacker can just guess what UI I chose
by a brute-force algorithm over or
something like that and if my I choose M
to be large or if I choose all the UI's
to be large to choose choose them from a
large range then my M is going to be
very large and this density is low and
that's vulnerable to the low density
attacks and so how lower densities
considered low so several people propose
that based on heuristics that if this
density is less than 0.45
then it's considered low density and it
can be attacked and this threshold is
had been improved all right
so but while most of the knapsack
cryptosystems are broken there are a few
that have so far stood the test of time
so they are so interesting because
knapsack problems website cryptosystems
will be much faster than RSA or any
number theory based we are just adding
numbers here right and RSA have this
operation where m is a 1000 bit number
and E is also a 1000 bit number and take
this exponentiation is actually very
slow so nap knapsack cryptosystem are
still interesting however their original
motivation turned out to be unsuccessful
the original motivation is to base
cryptography on np-complete problem
that's not going to work because NP
problems are hard only in the worst case
and we need cryptography to be hard in
average case why because if they are
only hard in worst case that means there
are several instances of the this
problem that are hard
so either you pick a secret key that
doesn't correspond to a hard problem or
you pick a secret key that's that
corresponds to a hard problem but
everyone else picks the same secret key
because everyone wants to be secure
that's the reason why it's unlikely to
get cryptography from any hard problems
okay that's all for today's recitation
and thanks everyone for the entire
semester
thank you for participation